[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
further enlightenment maintains against
the believer a right which the latter
himself concedes when enlightenment
regards the object of the believers
veneration as stone and wood or else is
something finite and anthropomorphic for
since this consciousness is divided
within itself having a beyond of the
real world in a world that is all
together this side of the world beyond
there is as a matter of fact also
present it at this view of the thing of
sense according to which accounts as a
being that is in and for itself but
faith does not bring together these two
thoughts of absolute being wich is for
it at one time pure essence and at
another time an ordinary thing of sense
even it's pure consciousness is affected
by the latter view for the differences
of the supersensible world because this
is without the notion are a series of
independent shapes and their movement is
a happening that as they exist only in
picture thinking and have within them
the marks of sensuous existence
enlightenment on its side equally
isolates the actual world as an entity
forsaken by spirit isolates determinate
necessity as if it were not even a
moment in the spiritual movement of
essential being not nothing but also not
something that absolutely is but
something that is evanescent
paragraph 567 continues this
enlightenment critique of faith as a
form of consciousness and now we've seen
that that Hegel has conceded several
times that faith it can present a kind
of initial opposition to where
enlightenment has been unfair to it but
that there is a deeper you know sort of
admission that has to be made if faith
is going to remain what it's supposed to
be which is a mode of thought a mode of
consciousness if it's going to attempt
to be adequate to itself as a movement
of spirit it has to admit certain things
now what's going on in this passage
continues that but there's also a very
interesting parallelism that I've
represented here between faith and
enlightenment that's going to show us
some of the emptiness of the
Enlightenment perspective as well let's
look at the text first so he says
enlightenment maintains against the
believer a right which the latter
himself concedes the enlightenment is
you know maintaining a sort of stance a
critical stance and if the person who is
a believer is genuinely motivated in
terms of spirit in terms of thought they
have to admit this and he says when
enlightenment regards the object of the
believers veneration as stone and wood
or as something to finite and
anthropomorphic so you know let's think
again what are we talking about here the
object of veneration the object of
action in this case as well what do we
what are we thinking about it could be a
statue it could be a place like a temple
some sort of finite limited location
where there's a differentiation being
made between sacred here and profane
over there outside
could be a religious text it could be
something that's movable from place to
place think of the function of the Ark
of the Covenant in you know ancient
Hebrew religion as we see it you know
depicted in in some of the Hebrew
Scriptures and we could go on and on and
on all these examples point towards one
common feature that Hegel is outlining
here there's something finite right it
is it is set apart from other things
being finite doesn't just mean being
limited
it means being limited in relation to
other things and anthropomorphic made
after the form or shape of humanity
here's where we get into some really
interesting let's call them reflections
because if you think about what is the
nature of the human being in relation to
the divine and let's just take a few
examples you know what do the hebrew
scriptures and then this is reaffirmed
by you know the Christian scriptures
what do they say about the human being
that they are made in the image or after
the image capital a cone of God
what Hegel's saying is yes but human
beings are also making gods after their
own image and this is a long-standing
tension within religion and we could
call it a you know intra religious
dialogue if we want to be euphemistic
about it let's call it inter-religious
polemic that was one of the fundamental
criticisms that the early Christians had
about the pagan religions that they were
simply anthropomorphizing and that you
know the the
the human being you know is really made
in the image of God rather than you know
the opposite way around doing it that
way the way the pagans are doing it is a
mistake and yet at the same time they
have a very answer PO morphic religion
because they have this figure Jesus
Christ right who's showing up God as
human and we could go on and on and on
with examples of this so coming back to
the text right Hegel says since this
consciousness
what's this consciousness the
consciousness of faith is divided within
itself how is it divided within itself
he tells us it has a beyond of the real
world that yang Zeitz the on the other
side something going past that so we've
already seen this in the unhappy
consciousness section right it has a
beyond of the real world and a world
that is all together this side of the
world beyond right so we have a dividing
line here that we can draw but it's kind
of a shifting line because you know
depending on where you are sort of in
the development of the theology what
counts is beyond might be you know
further beyond some things that are of
the world might be considered beyond for
a while then they get cast on on this
side the you know worldly right so he
says there's a matter of fact also
present in it this view of the thing of
sense the the idol the the statue the
text whatever it happens to be the thing
of sense according to which it counts as
a being that is in and for itself but
here's the problem
faith does not bring together these two
thoughts of absolute being wich is for
it at one time pure essence and at
another time an ordinary thing of sense
faith may try to do this by talking
about the finite thing of the sensuous
world as being merely a symbol or a
stand-in
our representative you know think for
example about the Christian reflections
on the status of the priests in the
celebration of you know the central meal
you know the priest stands as they say
in local crease to write Curtis days
rather in the place of Christ you know
as an intermediary now Hegel is saying
this is all great but these things have
a tendency to come separate from each
other and so there's this emphasis on
the beyond as being the real meaning of
what what's happening here and something
you know this connection this mediation
starts to seem rather arbitrary you know
so he goes on and he says faith doesn't
bring together these these two thoughts
right even in its pure consciousness he
says it's affected by the latter view
for the differences of the supersensible
world because this is without the notion
are a series of independent shapes and
their movement is a happening they occur
in time so he says they exist only in
picture thinking and have within them
the marks of sensuous existence
what is Hegel referring to here sacred
narrative sacred narrative becomes a
matter of things that are told so maybe
we move away from a statue and now we
have the story of what the statue
represents and yet it's still within
time it's still finite in that way for
Hegel this constitutes a real problem
and and this is felt to be a problem by
people of faith during the time that
he's talking about
many of them are grappling with this and
trying to make sense of it both within
the Protestant spectrum and within the
Catholic world of Hegel's time and and
the
centuries just preceding it so now he
says enlightenment here's where we get
to the parallelism on its side equally
isolates the actual world is an entity
forsaken by spirit isolates determinate
nests as an unmoved finitude so what are
we talking about they're determinate
determinate nests as an unmoved finitude
it's enlightenment is also setting up a
similar kind of this side and Beyond
while attempting to bring it all
together in one coherent account but at
this point it's not truly succeeding in
this for two reasons on the one hand the
actual world and the beings within it
including the subject the human subject
who's making sense of this is too static
that's where faith actually had some
sort of advantage it can tell some
pretty cool stories and enlightenment
stories are not really that gripping are
they even in our own time you know when
we talk about the you know post
enlightenment and we're in the late
modern or postmodern
and people have a hankering to go back
to the Enlightenment usually when they
tell a story that's you know making us
you know think that the Enlightenment is
a great thing it's because they're
telling some heroic tale which actually
looks a lot more like what's going on
with faith it's picture thinking for
being really serious about this stuff it
seems kind of anemic it seems kind of
toothless and this is one of the
problems with enlightenment and with
rationalism in general so he goes on he
says enlightenment isolates the actual
world as an entity forsaken by spirit
isolates the terminus is unmoved
finitude as if it were not even a moment
in the spiritual movement of essential
being the essential being you know the
supreme being the subject without
predicates is placed over here as we've
seen as a void as something that's you
know ultimately good but what is that
goodness consistent now we don't really
know well we can't understand it through
its effects in nature there's a sort of
day as I'm talking right the natural law
that's implanted in us that's all this
worldly though isn't it so he goes on
and he says as if it we're not even a
moment to the spiritual movement of
essential being not nothing but also not
something that absolutely is but
something that is evanescent so we have
a kind of bifurcation and thought here
in the Enlightenment as well even the
actual world is being treated as if it's
a static set of entities and at the same
time as just a happening as something
evanescent and the question of how its
reconnected with the absolute is still
left open so the Enlightenment is
engaging in this critique of faith faith
if it's going to be honest with itself
has to admit that it doesn't have its
own act together entirely with respect
to this but enlightenment Hegel is
hinting also has its own problems
it is clear that the same is the case
with the ground of knowledge faith
itself acknowledges a contingent
knowledge for it has a relationship to
contingent things an absolute being
itself exists for faith in the form of a
pictorial representation of a common
reality consequently the believing
consciousness - is a certainty which
does not possess the truth within itself
and it confesses itself to be such an
essential consciousness to be of this
world and separated from the spirit that
is certain of itself and self
authenticated but it forgets this moment
in its immediate spiritual knowledge of
absolute being enlightenment however
which reminds it of this in its turn
things only of contingent being and
forgets the other thinks only of the
mediation which takes place through an
alien third term not of the mediation in
which the immediate is itself the third
term through which it mediates itself
with the other that is with its own self
paragraph 568 continues this
enlightenment critique of faith there's
also a parallelism there towards the end
similar to the previous paragraph where
Hegel himself is adopting a critical
stance on enlightenment we could talk
about this as the negation of the
negation which means that Hegel is not
actually taking sides with faith but
using enlightenment own critique of
faith to point something out within
enlightenment but the the bulk of the
the focus here the bulk of the the
paragraph has to do with enlightenment
own critique of faith as a standpoint
that it is not fully adequate to itself
and is coming to realize that as such
through the critique that enlightenment
is providing of it so he says it's the
same it's clear the same as the case
with the ground of knowledge faith
itself acknowledges a contingent
knowledge for it has a relationship to
contingent beings what do we mean by
this well faith is historically bound
and even if we're talking about faiths
religions that are not particularly you
know interested in in sacred history or
something like that there's still you
know contingently connected with
particular objects or places or rituals
or whatever and through them one is
supposed to gain knowledge of the divine
and if you think about the the way that
that training or catechesis or teaching
works you're being introduced to these
contingent things and told perhaps this
is the God or this symbolizes the God
and you you know you could ask as
children often do well why this thing
then why why this and not that thing
over there you know why did you make the
I'd a lot of this kind of stone instead
of making out of this why does the
sacred text say this instead of saying
this other thing and you know the answer
is generally unsatisfying at least for
for thinking people
it just happens to be that way we don't
quite know or they come up with some
other explanation for it that ends up
opening the door to all sorts of other
possible interpretations well you know
God chose to manifest himself or itself
in this way because of the suitability
of this particular thing I mean we see
great examples of this with discussions
within you know medieval Christianity
why did you know why did God choose to
to manifest himself in a man you know
the argument that is priest can only be
men rather than as a woman you know and
and some of the gyrations that
theologians go through in trying to
explain this are you know they become a
little bit comical but also a little bit
tragic when you realize that they're not
great arguments they're based on
suitability that often depends on well
women are just inferior to men in this
respect or that respect and then you're
like oh what if we don't accept that
premise then then you know that's the
problem with contingent knowledge you
know we can we can take a new critical
standpoint on it and that's what
enlightenment in fact is doing so he
says faith acknowledges a contingent
knowledge relationship to contingent
things and absolute being itself exists
for faith and here Hegel has a really
interesting phrase exists as how Miller
is translating this a pictorial
representation of common reality now the
the German is a little bit more direct
for gosh Talton combined in V R Klee
okay right the the vehicle type reality
actuality we've seen that term being
used a lot it's interesting that he says
give mine in here and instead of you
know other possible things so it's not
Universal it's it's common it's not olga
Myna it's give mine in right it is
something that belongs to us as a
commune
religious belief or our faith and then
the the pictorial representation that's
a sort of you know circuit
circumlocution around the for gosh
Delton it is it is depicted it is
represented it is you know if we want to
be much more direct it is set out there
it is framed out there it is ways we
could think about this and so we have a
common reality a common actuality is
probably a better way of translating
this an actuality that we all agree on
to some degree you know God in is heaven
you know or the the Trinity or you know
pick whatever else you you like and this
could include the entire cosmos the the
world understood as beyond and we kind
of you know we all agree about it but if
you ask us what we really mean by what
we agree with or how we picture it in
our heads
then divergences show up and then we
have to realize the contingency of what
it is that we're thinking about great
example of this is if you look at
depictions of the Theotokos in
iconography the Theotokos is Mary
depicted as the mother of God so this is
something stemming from Christian
theology and you know it was something
that was was decided at one of the
councils Mary is indeed the Theotokos
you know the bearer of God and it was
depicted in all sorts of interesting
icons and if you look at iconography
you're going to see stylistic
divergences from you know within the the
great you know linguistic and and
ecclesiastical traditions in the church
so you know is icons in the Syriac
speaking churches don't look quite the
same as they do in the originally Greek
and then all these other national
tongues Orthodox churches they don't
look quite the same most of the Catholic
stuff is kind of calm
be from the Eastern Orthodox oh but
there is some some differences and then
we can talk about say you know the
Coptic icons and all that and that's all
within you know one overarching way
Konomi k-11 cultural sphere what happens
when you take the Theotokos to China and
you depict Mary with the infant Jesus
who's you know God right and within
Christianity in a way that draws upon
the aesthetic sensibilities and Canon
and also other religious ideas of the
Chinese cultural sphere well then you
get Mary depicted as Guan Yin goddess of
mercy who's actually a you know a
Buddhist figure coming from India
originally and then making its way into
China and you could say you know
somebody encountering that from the West
might say I don't really recognize that
as a depiction of the absolute being and
the absolute beings mom hey they might
say this is just you know some depiction
of a goddess or you know if they they're
a little bit more on the ball and they
know something about Buddhism they might
talk about that that history you know
how this this originally male figure
there's Bodhisattva transfers across the
Himalayas and becomes a female figure in
China they may not recognize it because
of the contingency and we can go on and
on and on about this this is where you
know you get a little bit of a
digression hermeneutics comes in and
it's not just hermeneutics of the text
but hermeneutics of culture figuring out
what it is that people actually mean by
the things that they are depicting or
representing or imagining together
sometimes we have to reconstitute that
together that's what hermeneutics is
about re-establishing the gamaya so
I spent a lot of time at that first
sentence let's go let's go on
he says consequently the believing
consciousness is a certainty which does
not possess the truth within itself and
it confesses itself to be such an
unofficial consciousness to be of this
world and separated from the spirit that
is certain of its off and sell
authenticated so faith realizes that it
is separated from absolute being even by
the very means that it attempts to use
to conceptualize and to connect with
absolute being in this case through
knowledge and you know we do see this
represented within faith throughout the
world religions discussions about the
inadequacy of symbols and analogy to
truly reveal to us what the divine is in
itself so he says it forgets this moment
in its immediate spiritual knowledge of
absolute being so faith is oscillating
between a realization of its own
inadequacy and a sort of being
fascinated and forget forgetting by
focusing on the contingent things so
enlightenment comes in and says gotcha
here's the critique you you guys are you
know taking the divine and representing
it in all these ways this is not a new
thing we've already seen this worked out
in paragraph after paragraph before now
let's look at what Hegel says about
enlightenment itself this gets really
interesting
he says enlightenment which reminds it
of this in its turn thinks only of
contingent being and forgets the other
it thinks only of the mediation this is
where it gets a little metaphysical and
a little bit methodological we got to
follow at Hegel saying here thinks only
of the mediation which takes place
through an alien third term what is that
alien third term contingent beings of
the world in the case of enlightenment
sensuous beings right so he says takes
place through an alien third term
but it doesn't grasp the mediation in
which the immediate is itself the third
term through which it mediates itself
with the other that is with its own self
so that you know when you read that the
first time you like what is he talking
about there well let's think about that
it's not thinking of the mediation which
in which the immediate is itself the
third term through which it mediates
itself with the other a more complex
attitude the immediacy of faith for a
self-conscious faith could be understood
in terms of its vary in AK inadequacy to
the divine but it understands that this
is the best that it's got and it uses
that as a way to in some respect move
beyond itself but also bring itself
along as it moves beyond to progress to
develop as we say so would this get it
to the divine not necessarily but it
gets it further towards the divine and
enlightenment is missing out on this so
in a certain respect it's not only
misunderstanding faith its
misunderstanding what faith does that
enlightenment itself could be doing in
relation to its own conception of
absolute being and contingent being it's
not understanding itself adequately as a
subject
you